Hundreds of arthritis victims who were resigned to a life
of agonizing pain are now enjoying pain-free motion
in the knees, hips, and back once again,
thanks to a new miracle at home protocol
that doesn't involve drugs, injections, or surgery,
says its discoverer, Dr. Paul Cox.
According to Dr. Cox's laboratory analyses,
in case after case, this totally safe and natural approach,
end heat and swelling in affected joints
within three to 10 days.
Relieves pain and, in most cases,
eliminates pain entirely in two weeks or less,
allows more normal movement of affected parts
in three weeks or less, restores damaged bone structure
in most cases in three to six months.
Now Harvard scientists report the same results
in clinical trials conducted in early 2026.
In clinical trials, X-ray images show Dr. Paul Cox's
natural-at-home approach rapidly improves
bone structure in arthritis.
Knee caps were unfusing themselves,
compressed vertebrae were regenerating,
while joint spacing, cartilage, and synovial fluid levels
visibly returned toward normal, lubricating joints
and allowing smoother movement without friction.
One of the first people who tried this discovery
was the Hollywood star Morgan Freeman.
I tried every top pain treatment
in the U.S. money could buy 15 years of it,
but the pain only got worse.
It took me 10 minutes just to get out of bed.
Stairs felt like torture, a sharp pain
that makes you stop halfway up.
That knife in the knee feeling, it keeps you on edge.
You don't just stand up and walk anymore.
You think about it first.
After a while, I just accepted it.
That's my life now.
When Sanjay told me about Dr. Cox's work,
I thought an at-home protocol
that actually reverses years of joint damage, really?
Still, I tried it.
Within the first week, the heat and swelling
in my knee were gone completely.
By the end of the second week,
that sharp, stabbing pain had left.
A few days later, my daughter saw me going up the stairs
and said, Dad, you didn't even ask for help.
I hadn't done that in years.
This was no isolated case.
In recent clinical trials, Dr. Cox's natural at-home approach
was tested head-to-head against the very drugs
most arthritis sufferers depend on.
Advil, Aleve, Celebrex, Tramadol,
and even cortisone injections.
And the results surprised even the specialists.
In the study, 89% of participants reported joint stiffness,
heat and swelling dramatically reduced
within the first week.
84% resumed normal daily activities
without discomfort or pain in two weeks or less.
92% reported almost no pain
or mobility difficulty after four weeks.
X-rays showed progressive bone regeneration
and restoration of synovial fluid over time.
By the end of the study,
most participants returned
for their final evaluation independently,
without assistance from family members
and without using conventional pain medications.
To understand how Dr. Cox's natural protocol
is helping people across America,
even in decade-long bone-on-bone cases
and seniors confined to wheelchairs,
move freely and live without pain.
We invited Dr. Sanjay Gupta, renowned neurosurgeon
and CNN's chief medical correspondent,
who traveled to Wyoming to interview Dr. Paul Cox personally
and answer two critical questions.
What is this natural protocol
that's reversing joint damage
and restoring pain-free movement?
Even in severe bone-on-bone cases.
And how exactly are people using it at home,
step-by-step, to walk, climb stairs
and move through the day without pain
in just a couple of weeks?
When we began investigating chronic back,
knee and hip pain, something didn't make sense.
For 50 years, medicine told us
it was simply wear and tear, age, genetics.
But when we examined the data more closely,
it became clear that wasn't the whole story.
That trail led us to a small nonprofit laboratory
in the mountains of Wyoming,
where Dr. Paul Cox has been studying pain biology
and joint aging for years.
The visible damage, worn-down cartilage,
bone grinding on bone, that's not the real problem.
In fact, that's a symptom.
It's like coughing during a cold.
You don't treat the cough alone.
You treat the cold so the cough goes away.
I'll be honest, as a physician, I was skeptical at first.
Dr. Cox didn't just discover how to stop joint damage.
What we saw, again and again,
was the joint rebuilding itself.
Worn bones rebuilding, cartilage growing back,
synovial fluid refilling, joints gliding smoothly again.
Just like a cut on your skin closes,
just like a broken bone heals over time.
The joint structure was rebuilding itself,
day after day, without bone-on-bone grinding,
without stiffness, without pain.
And this discovery didn't come
from a traditional orthopedist,
but from a Harvard-trained ethnobotanist.
Ethnobotanist, what exactly does that mean?
I'm a cure hunter.
I was trained to live among indigenous peoples
and decode how they use herbs, plants, and natural foods
to protect and cure themselves from disease.
The logical path is to look at extremes,
places where pain is rare, and places where it's everywhere.
The difference between them reveals
what's actually causing the pain.
When Dr. Cox began following this pattern,
it led him somewhere unexpected,
a small island in the Pacific called Guam.
In Guam, what did you find there?
It was devastating.
Nearly one out of every four adults
could barely walk without support.
Knees grinding bone-on-bone, hips locking mid-step,
spines collapsing before 60,
every family had someone on a cane, a walker,
a wheelchair, or waiting for joint replacement.
That wasn't normal aging.
Something was wrong.
Rates of severe arthritis and crippling back pain
were dozens of times higher than anywhere else.
Age couldn't explain it.
Genetics couldn't explain it either.
So Dr. Paul Cox asked one question, what changed?
An industrial plant was built right next
to the community's main drinking water source.
And after that, year after year, joint pain cases surged.
First, the grandparents, then the parents,
then people in their 40s, then even their 30s.
That's when we tested the water.
And what we found was alarming, cadmium chloride,
a highly inflammatory toxin,
at levels I had never seen in my career.
At first, I assumed it was just a local
water contamination issue,
but as I read your full research,
I realized something far more disturbing.
This wasn't just Guam, cadmium chloride is everywhere.
Exactly.
And here's the tricky part.
In Guam, cadmium chloride levels were so high
they were easy to detect.
But in smaller amounts,
it slips past standard safety tests.
In fact, only a few labs in the entire U.S.
can properly measure it.
At Harvard, we ran advanced tests
capable of finding even small amounts of cadmium chloride.
And what we found shocked us.
Cadmium chloride was present
in nearly every kitchen across America.
There is no way to fully escape it.
It's in pesticide sprayed on crops.
It's in factory waste seeping into soil and rivers.
It's in the packaging your groceries come in.
It's in the water from your kitchen tap
and inside bottled water.
Even in everyday fruits like apples,
strawberries and blueberries,
not at Guam's extreme levels,
but high enough enough to build up inside the body,
enough to inflame,
enough to quietly damage joints over time.
But you found a solution for this, right?
A natural one?
Not me.
The answer was already there.
We just had to look in the right place.
After years of studying
how cadmium chloride damages the joints,
we discovered something medicine had overlooked for decades.
The solution for chronic pain
wasn't a new drug or surgery.
The truth is,
it already existed in nature this whole time.
It's in two natural compounds that work together.
So how do these natural compounds
actually repair the damage inside the joints?
It's actually simple.
One helps the body clear out cadmium chloride.
The other helps damaged joints rebuild.
And this is where most treatments fail,
because in the knees, hips and spine,
the ends of the bones are covered
by a protective layer called cartilage
and surrounded by a slippery natural lubricant
called synovial fluid.
Together, they prevent your bones
from rubbing against each other
every time you stand, walk or bend.
And this is where the pain begins.
Cadmium chloride slowly eats away cartilage,
the smooth cushion protecting the joints.
At the same time, it dries up synovial fluid,
the natural lubricant inside the joints.
So instead of moving smoothly,
the bones begin to grind against each other day after day
that grinding strips the joint down to bare bone
until even a small movement
causes a sudden knife twist of pain out of nowhere.
Then it happens again and again
to the point where standing up
becomes something to think about first.
And little by little,
independence starts slipping away.
So these two natural compounds,
how do they actually reverse what you just described?
And what exactly are these compounds?
Where did you find them?
I didn't start in a laboratory.
I started by looking at places where we would expect
to see the same level of chronic pain as Guam.
But then I found regions where pain was rare
and that raised a critical question.
What are they doing differently?
My first expedition took me to rural India.
There I met men and women in their 60s and 70s
still working the fields every day.
They harvest under the sun for hours.
They lift baskets of crops.
They carry water by hand.
They squat again and again.
Their joints simply did not match their age.
Even more surprising, in these villages,
you don't see canes, you don't see walkers.
Wheelchairs are rare.
Most had never even heard the words joint replacement.
So I had to ask, how can joints use that heavily
day after day, stay pain-free for decades?
So we watched what they did.
Every evening, almost without exception,
they drank a warm preparation made from a golden root,
a root their culture has used for generations.
Back in the lab, we finally understood why.
It increases blood flow inside the joint.
You see blood is how the body repairs itself.
When you cut your skin, blood rushes to the area.
It carries repair cells with it.
And little by little, the tissue rebuilds.
The same repair process happens inside your joints.
This golden root drives nutrient-rich blood directly
in a damaged cartilage.
It allows your body to rebuild cartilage
and restore the slippery fluid that
keeps bones from grinding.
And that's what allows joints to move smoothly again
without pain.
But we discovered something critical.
You can't rebuild joint tissue while cadmium chloride
is still attacking it.
If cadmium chloride keeps building up,
repairs simply won't hold.
So before we rebuilt anything, we
had to remove the poison.
So the golden root repairs the joint.
But if cadmium chloride is still there, how do you remove it?
This question led us to a rare mountain honey in Japan.
For generations, people there have
used it as a daily tonic for the joints.
In the lab, we saw why.
This honey is rich in flavonoids.
Flavonoids are natural compounds that
behave almost like tiny magnets in the body.
They stick to cadmium chloride.
And when the body naturally eliminates these flavonoids
through urine, the cadmium chloride
leaves the body with them.
Once the toxin is gone, the joint repair process
can finally hold.
So just to be clear, the Japanese honey
removes the cadmium from the body,
stopping the destructive process inside the joint.
And the Indian golden root restores the joint tissue,
rebuilding cartilage, and restoring
the fluid that keeps bones from grinding.
So joints move smoothly again.
Exactly.
First, you remove what's damaging the joint,
then you allow the body to rebuild it properly.
Before presenting this publicly, Dr. Cox
insisted on validating the findings in humans.
The study was conducted in Wyoming
using volunteers between the ages of 55 and 75
who had been living with chronic knee, hip, or lower back pain
for several years.
Retired ranchers, veterans, former construction workers,
homemakers, people who had already
been told their joint damage was permanent,
progressive, irreversible.
The first step was blood analysis.
We used specialized laboratory testing
capable of detecting low level cadmium chloride accumulation.
52 out of 54 participants tested positive.
That confirmed what we suspected.
The toxin was present.
Each participant received a daily tablet containing
concentrated Japanese mountain honey
and the Indian golden root.
No additional medications were introduced.
And what did you find?
Honestly, what surprised us wasn't whether it worked.
It was how quickly it worked.
Within the first three to 10 days,
heat and swelling in affected joints
were significantly reduced.
In two weeks or less, most participants
reported substantial pain relief.
In many cases, the pain was completely gone.
Within three weeks, mobility tests
showed near normal movement in daily activities,
including climbing stairs, standing up from a chair,
and walking comfortably.
And over the next three to six months,
x-rays and MRI scans confirmed structural repair
inside the joint.
Areas of worn-down bones showed significant bone regrowth.
Bone strength returned toward normal levels.
Joint spacing improved, eliminating
the bone-on-bone contact.
This was not symptom masking.
It was structural repair, the kind of structural repair
we normally see only after surgery.
If these results held up on a larger scale,
it would change the way we think about joint medicine.
So Dr. Cox decided to test it more rigorously.
In 2025, Dr. Cox led a large-scale clinical trial
at Harvard.
In the study, more than 4,000 participants
suffering from severe arthritis, chronic back pain,
bone-on-bone knees, and hip degeneration
received a daily 750 milligram dose of Japanese honey
combined with Indian golden root extract.
And once again, the results were clear.
In the first week, 89% of participants
reported that joint stiffness, heat, and swelling
were dramatically reduced.
In two weeks or less, 84% resumed normal daily activities
without significant discomfort or pain.
Within just 30 days, 92% of participants,
including those who depended on family members
or even used wheelchairs for daily movement,
reported dramatic pain relief.
Many were climbing stairs and walking daily
without pain or mobility limitations.
After six months on the treatment,
the results impressed even Harvard orthopedic doctors.
Six-month follow-up x-rays and MRI scans
showed clear bone regeneration and restoration
of the cartilage and lubricant fluid that
keep the bones from grinding as long as participants
stayed on the treatment.
This confirms that consistent daily use is critical,
not just for relieving pain, but for real joint repair that
continues month after month.
Each one of those numbers was a life
that had been shrinking because of pain,
but now they tell a very different story.
I've run cattle my whole life.
For 10 years, my right knee pain was a 12 out of 10.
It would lock up getting out of bed.
Stepping onto the tractor felt like somebody
was driving a nail into the back of it.
Climbing into the loft, forget it.
Now I jump fences, climb on the tractor,
and walk my land without thinking about my knee.
The pain's gone.
Zero.
It's just not an issue anymore.
I'm a metal fabricator.
I'm twisting, lifting, on my feet all day.
My right knee used to hurt deep inside, constant.
It even started bowing out from all that pressure.
Now, there's no pain in that knee.
None.
I don't think about it anymore.
I move fast again.
I can run if I need to.
I get down on the floor with my grandkids
and stand back up without bracing myself.
It's just solid.
Feels normal again.
For 17 years, my right knee was bone on bone.
It hurt so bad it would wake me up
five or six times a night, walking downstairs.
I had to do this little hop just to get down.
Getting into the car, I had to physically
lift my leg with my hands.
Now I walk up subway steps without thinking about it.
I bike three or four times a week.
I'm back to kickboxing.
And the best part, there's no pain, none.
My right leg feels completely normal again.
I was bone on bone in both knees.
No cartilage left.
My legs were so bowed out, they hurt all the time.
Just walking across my clinic was exhausting.
I'm a veterinarian.
I'm on my feet all day.
I couldn't afford to be down long.
Now I walk straight again.
No pain, none.
Clients keep asking if I lost weight.
I didn't.
I just got my height back.
I walk the dogs with my wife as long as she wants to go.
I'm back landscaping my yard.
My knees just feel normal again.
I've had osteoarthritis in my knees for almost 20 years.
I'm a waitress.
I'm on my feet all night carrying trays.
There were nights I could barely walk to my car.
And when I got home, I had to sit there for a minute
just to get out.
I remember thinking, this can't be my life at 53.
Now I finish a shift and I'm still standing straight.
I walk to my car without limping.
I bring groceries by myself.
And the pain, it's completely gone.
My knees don't control my day anymore.
This is always a difficult question.
But if it were your own mother or your father,
would you recommend this?
I wouldn't just recommend it.
I already do.
I've seen it work in my own family.
And I've personally seen it work in hundreds of men and women
who were told their joint damage was permanent.
People who struggled with the simplest things,
who avoided stairs, who could barely make it to the front door,
who stopped trusting their own body,
who felt like a burden to their family,
who started saying no to invitations,
even to their grandkids,
because the pain was running their lives.
And now they're enjoying a pain-free life again.
Climbing stairs without second guessing,
walking every morning back in the garden,
back on the farm, traveling again,
and even playing with their grandkids,
they're living their golden years,
not just surviving them.
Seeing results like these made my mission clear.
No one deserves to feel like a prisoner
inside their own body.
I felt an obligation to make this joint restoration formula
available to every American who feels trapped by joint pain,
who's watching their independence slowly slip away.
And today, this formula is finally ready for people
who refuse to live with chronic joint pain.
After years of research and clinical validation,
Dr. Cox's joint restoring formula is now available.
It's called core strength.
Core strength is the first natural formula
designed to target the true root cause
of chronic joint pain in the knees, hips, and back.
Toxic cadmium buildup that breaks down cartilage,
dries out the fluid that keeps joints lubricated
and prevents your body from repairing itself.
Every capsule of core strength combines
Japanese mountain honey and Indian golden root
in clinically proven concentrations,
clearing toxic cadmium from the joints
and helping your body rebuild cartilage
and restore natural lubrication
so movement becomes smooth and easy again.
In fact, after rigorous FDA analysis,
this formula consistently restored normal joint mobility,
even in severe joint degeneration cases
where people had lived in daily pain
for over 15 years, now thousands across America
in their 50s, 60s, 70s, and even 80s
are living independently again
without asking anyone for help.
I'm 100 years old.
I don't know how much time I've got left.
What I do know is I don't wanna spend it stuck in a chair.
The pain in my knees had me depending on everyone.
After a couple of weeks on core strength,
I could get up on my own again.
I walk around the house without holding onto things.
I can walk in my garden, drive, take care of myself.
At my age, that's all I ask for.
It doesn't matter how many diagnoses you've received.
Osteoarthritis, bone-on-bone knees,
hip degeneration, severe lower back pain,
or herniated discs.
And it doesn't matter if you were told injections,
painkillers, or surgery were your only option.
Once the cadmium is out of your system
and your joint begins restoring itself,
that deep bone-on-bone grind rapidly fades away.
You wake up without that stiff,
locked-up feeling in your knee.
You stand up and put your foot on the floor,
and there's no sharp stab.
You walk to the bathroom without stopping halfway.
You climb stairs without gripping the railing.
You tie your shoes without thinking about it.
You bend down to grab the remote.
You carry groceries without that deep grinding pain.
And for the first time in years,
you're not waiting for the pain to hit
because the results have been so consistent.
Dr. Paul Cox is offering a money-back guarantee
to anybody who uses core strength
without experiencing significant relief from joint pain
within the first 10 days.
Not temporary masking, but lasting relief
that continues as long as you stay on the protocol.
How can he make such a confident guarantee?
The answer is simple.
There are seven reasons.
One, core strength targets the true root cause
of joint pain.
Most pain treatments only mask the pain temporarily
while the wear and tear continues getting worse.
Core strength works at the source of the problem.
It helps clear toxic cadmium buildup from your joints.
The buildup that wears down cartilage
dries out natural lubrication
and leads to that painful bone-on-bone grinding.
Once cadmium is removed,
your joints can rapidly begin restoring themselves,
just like your body heals a wound
or repairs a broken bone.
Two, core strength restores damaged joints
from the inside out.
It increases circulation deep inside the joint,
delivering repair cells directly to worn cartilage and bone
that have been grinding against each other for years.
Restoring the parts your joint needs
for smooth pain-free movement,
the protective cartilage, the cushioning joint fluid,
the bone surfaces, which means every step feels smooth
and steady, free from that sharp grinding pain.
Three, core strength has been clinically validated
in severe long-term joint damage.
It was tested in individuals
with extreme bone-on-bone degeneration,
including those who relied on wheelchairs
or needed assistance with basic daily tasks.
Even in severe cases,
participants regain the ability to stand on their own,
walk across a room without support
and move through their home independently again,
restoring mobility and independence
many believed were gone for good.
Four, most people notice significant pain relief
within two weeks or less.
In clinical trials, nine out of 10 participants
reported substantial relief from joint pain
within the first two weeks of using core strength.
Many reported simple movements felt normal again
with little to no pain when standing up from a chair,
walking, climbing stairs,
or bending down to pick something up.
Five, the repair and protection continue month after month.
Core strength doesn't just relieve pain
in the first couple of weeks.
While you're already moving better,
it continues clearing cadmium
and rebuilding the joint at the same time.
So you're not just getting temporary fast relief.
You're restoring the joint and protecting it
from bone-on-bone grinding long-term,
ensuring you stay independent
and keep living life on your terms.
Six, the formula is designed
for maximum absorption and effectiveness.
Most supplements lose a large portion of their strength
the moment they hit stomach acid.
By the time they reach your system,
much of the active ingredient has already been wasted.
Core strength is different.
Its advanced capsule is built with a natural pectin coating
that resists stomach acid and releases its nutrients
where they are actually absorbed in your intestine.
That means nearly the entire formula
reaches your bloodstream intact,
delivering maximum potency directly to your joints.
Seven, every bottle is made
in an FDA certified laboratory right here in the USA.
Only the very best and highest quality ingredients are used.
There are no common allergens.
There is no sugar, no salt, no shellfish,
no artificial preservatives or dyes,
nothing that will interfere with your blood sugar
or blood pressure.
In fact, it is completely safe
to take alongside your daily medications,
including blood pressure, diabetes and cholesterol pills
and even your daily vitamins
with zero conflicts and zero side effects.
That means you can take core strength
every single day with total peace of mind.
That's why doctors, rheumatologists
and thousands of Americans choose this formula
over drugs, injections and joint replacement surgery.
I've seen patients with severe bone-on-bone degeneration
report dramatic pain relief in under two weeks
with core strength,
able to resume normal daily activities on their own.
In 30 years of practice,
I've never seen joints respond this quickly,
even in post-surgical recovery.
For 12 years, I've watched good, hardworking men
and women reach retirement,
only to feel limited by joint pain.
Many relied on injections that wear off quickly.
Others weren't ready to face joint replacement surgery
because of the cost or recovery.
Now, with core strength,
I can finally offer them a safe, non-surgical option,
one that not only relieves pain,
but actively helps repair the damage inside the joint.
I've personally seen significant pain reduction
in 26 patients who used it last month.
When I saw clear improvement in my first patient,
a severe bone-on-bone case,
I knew this wasn't something I could ignore.
Since then, I've recommended core strength
to every patient in my clinic
who is struggling with joint pain,
especially those who aren't good candidates for surgery.
In fact, I had my own father try it.
He's 82 and wasn't eligible for joint replacement
because of his heart condition.
Within the first two weeks,
his pain dropped significantly.
He used to spend the entire day on the couch
because every step hurt.
Now he's back tinkering around the house.
He goes through the day on his own again.
As both a surgeon and a son,
that meant everything to me.
And now, I'd like to invite you
to try core strength for yourself completely risk-free.
It's easy to use core strength.
Just take one capsule in the morning after breakfast.
That's it.
A simple daily habit that can change how you move,
walk, and live.
Just imagine for a moment.
You wake up a few days from now.
You put your feet on the floor,
and when you stand, there's no stab, no locked joints,
no grinding, no pain at all.
You put your full weight on your legs
and walk to the bathroom without even thinking about it.
Then you make your coffee.
And instead of spending the whole day stuck on the couch,
you tie your shoes and head out for a walk
around the neighborhood.
You walk steady, easy.
You wave to a neighbor passing by.
You hear birds singing.
You breathe the fresh morning air
without stopping every few steps,
waiting for that stab of pain.
You just walk like you used to.
Think about it.
How much would it be worth to climb the stairs
without stopping halfway?
To go buy your groceries,
carry the bags into your kitchen,
and put everything away on your own.
How much would it be worth to go to church again?
Stand during the hymns,
stand during prayer,
without pain forcing you to sit down.
And what about your grandkids?
Imagine them running up to you and saying,
grandpa, grandma, come play with me.
And this time, instead of saying, I'm sorry, I can't,
you actually go outside and play in the yard with them.
Let that sink in for a second.
How much would it be worth to have your life back?
To be able to take care of yourself again,
to know your loved ones aren't worried about you anymore.
To wake up each morning and not wonder
how bad the pain will be today.
To move through your day like you used to,
that's priceless.
That's why when we finalized the core strength formula,
our biggest concern wasn't whether it worked.
We already had the clinical proof.
The real challenge was making it affordable
for the millions of people losing their mobility.
The golden root is sourced from remote regions of India,
growing in dry, sun-baked soil
where temperatures stay above 100 degrees for months.
That harsh climate forces the root
to produce powerful protective nutrients,
the very nutrients that help restore damaged joints.
On top of that, the Japanese mountain honey
comes from bees in the high mountains of Japan.
And it can only be harvested during a short 60-day window
each year when the honey reaches full maturity and potency.
So yes, core strength is costly to make,
but when you compare it to the alternatives,
you'll realize it is actually affordable.
Joint replacement surgery can cost $30,000, $40,000,
sometimes even more.
And that doesn't include the hospital stay,
the anesthesia, the months of painful rehab,
or the risk of complications.
Cortisone injections might seem cheaper at first,
but they wear off, so you go back.
And back again, paying hundreds, sometimes thousands,
every single year just to manage the pain.
And that doesn't even count the real cost,
the cost of losing your independence,
needing help just to stand up, to climb stairs,
to get in and out of a car,
leaving family or church gatherings early
because the pain won't let you stay,
sitting on the couch while everyone else
is out there laughing and living,
relying on your family to carry groceries,
to drive you places, to help you with simple things
you used to do without thinking.
When you really think about it, getting your strength back,
walking without that grinding pain,
living on your own terms again, that's priceless.
That's why Dr. Paul Cox refused to make core strength
available through CVS, Walgreens, or Walmart.
Once big stores get involved, they raise the price,
and that can easily push it well above $200 per bottle.
And he didn't think that was right
for people who need this.
So he made a simple decision to cut out every middleman
and deliver core strength directly to you,
right here on this page, no pharmacies,
no big store prices.
This way, core strength is just $99 per bottle,
a small price compared to the thousands of dollars
people spend every year just to temporarily mask pain.
Now, before you get yours, let me tell you something,
the results can be dramatic and fast.
I've seen it hundreds of times,
but true, deep joint repair, complete restoration takes time.
This is a treatment, not a miracle,
even though many patients say it feels like a miracle.
Think of it like training wheels on a bike.
At first, they help you start moving again,
quickly and without pain.
At the same time, the nutrients in core strength
work day and night repairing joint damage
and protecting your joints, helping keep that painful
bone-on-bone grinding from coming back.
That's why Dr. Paul Cox created
the complete joint repair treatment.
It includes six bottles of core strength,
the complete six-month treatment
that helps relieve pain within days,
while also repairing worn-down joints
and protecting them from further damage.
This is the very same treatment that's already
helped thousands of patients with severe joint pain walk,
move, and live comfortably again.
Normally, the complete joint repair treatment
would cost $594.
But because you're watching this presentation right now,
you can secure your treatment through a special offer.
Dr. Cox wants as many people as possible
to experience core strength and feel the difference
in their own joints.
So for the next 24 hours, you can secure the six-bottle
complete joint repair treatment for just $294.
That's only $49 per bottle.
And it's a one-time purchase.
You're not signing up for anything.
You order it once, and that's it.
No hidden charges.
What you see is exactly what you get.
And when you order today, shipping is absolutely free.
Now, for those who are just starting
to feel the first signs of joint discomfort,
there's a three-bottle kit of core strength
that provides the minimum three-month treatment.
It doesn't offer the full joint protection of the six-bottle
complete joint repair treatment, but it's still
a good option for anyone in the very early stages of pain,
stiffness, and loss of mobility.
Rest assured, your entire order is fully protected
by a 100% money-back guarantee.
If you are not completely satisfied for any reason
whatsoever, simply send an email to the address printed
on your core strength bottle any time,
and you'll receive an immediate refund
of every penny you paid, even if every bottle is empty.
No questions asked.
It's easy to order.
Look right below this video and choose the treatment
that's best for you.
I personally recommend the complete joint repair
treatment, the six-bottle supply,
because it helps relieve pain quickly
while repairing your joints and protecting them
from further damage.
Next, click the Buy Now button.
You'll be taken to a secure order page.
Simply enter your name, email, shipping address,
and payment details.
Then click to confirm your order.
That's it.
Your core strength will arrive on your doorstep
in as little as three days anywhere in the United States.
After that, you're the judge.
If you're not 100% satisfied for any reason at all,
simply send an email to the address printed
on your core strength bottle,
and you'll receive a full refund of every penny you paid.
No questions asked.
Now look below this video and choose the treatment
that's best for you.
If you don't see the Buy Now button below this video,
it means our current stock has sold out.
Remember, this special offer is available
only while the current batch lasts
to help Americans take back the life joint pain
stole from them.
People who once enjoyed walks around the neighborhood
ran up the stairs ahead of their grandkids,
pushed a full cart through the grocery store aisles,
and now spend most of the day stuck on the couch,
watching their independence slowly slip away.
That's why Dr. Cox cut out every middleman
so we can deliver core strength
at the lowest possible price
through this presentation today.
Once this batch is gone,
it may take up to eight months
before core strength is available again.
And to be completely honest,
with the number of patients already in treatment,
it's very likely the entire next batch
will be reserved for them first.
That's why we decided to do something special
for the first people who take action today.
The first 30 people who secure
the six-bottle complete joint repair treatment today
will also receive a private one-on-one online consultation
with Dr. Paul Cox.
During this session,
you'll be able to discuss your specific situation,
talk about your joint pain, stiffness, or mobility problems,
and even show any exams or diagnosis you may have received.
Dr. Cox will personally guide you
through what you can do each day
to help your joints recover faster
and move more comfortably.
Normally, a private consultation like this costs $400.
But today, when you secure
the six-bottle complete joint repair treatment,
it will be included completely free of charge.
However, because Dr. Cox can only speak
with a limited number of people personally,
this consultation is strictly limited
to the first 30 people
who secure their six-bottle treatment today.
Now, before I go,
I feel it's important I tell you about one more thing,
the cost of not taking care of your joints,
because this is not a problem that fixes itself.
If you're struggling with sharp pain in your joints,
in your knees, hips, or back,
if getting out of bed takes a while,
if simple things like walking or climbing stairs now hurt,
then your joints may already be grinding,
maybe even bone-on-bone.
Even if you're taking painkillers,
paying for physical therapy,
or getting cortisone injections,
the pain might go away for a while,
but the bones and the joints
are still rubbing against each other.
At first, it's subtle.
Maybe you stay on the couch more often.
Maybe you avoid stairs or long walks.
Maybe you start moving more slowly.
But eventually, the joint damage hurts so badly
that even simple things stop you cold.
Standing in the kitchen starts killing you.
Walking to the bathroom feels like torture.
Then you start depending on other people for basic things,
groceries, doctor visits, paying the bills,
and little by little, independence starts slipping away.
But that's not the full story.
When joint pain gets worse,
people naturally start moving less, less walking,
less standing, less moving around.
And when the body stops moving, muscles start shrinking.
And it happens fast.
This is called muscle atrophy.
Legs get weaker, balance gets worse.
Falls become more likely.
In fact, one out of every four adults over 65 falls each year.
And when a fall leads to a broken hip,
about one out of three people die within a year.
Not always from the fall itself,
but from what happens after.
Pneumonia, blood clots, infections, heart problems.
The truth is, many never walk the same way again.
Some end up in a wheelchair.
Others lose the ability to live on their own
and move into nursing homes.
And it often starts with simple joint pain
that keeps people from moving.
That's why it's important to take care of it now
before the joint damage gets worse.
Fortunately, there's now a way to stop joint damage
and rebuild your joints.
Simply take one capsule of core strength each morning.
Within just a few days,
you'll start noticing that moving feels easier day after day.
You get out of bed without that stiff, locked up feeling.
You walk to the mailbox.
You work in the garden like you used to.
You carry groceries, even the heavier bags.
You bend down to pick up the remote
without that sharp discomfort.
And this is not just temporary.
When you stay on the treatment for four to six months,
the body reverses years of damage in your joints.
Restoring cartilage, lubrication, even the bone structure.
Helping your joints move smoothly and feel strong again.
You saw what other people experienced.
Cal, the rancher whose knee used to lock up
climbing onto his tractor,
now jumps fences and walks his land
without thinking about it.
Mark, the metal fabricator whose knee hurt constantly
from twisting and lifting all day,
now moves fast again and gets down on the floor
with his grandkids.
And Diane, who lived with bone-on-bone pain for 17 years,
now climbs subway stairs, bikes several times a week,
and even does kickboxing again.
We could spend an entire month just showing story after story
from people who used core strength and reclaimed their lives.
Now the decision is yours.
If you want to reclaim your mobility,
your independence, and your life,
all you have to do is look below this video.
Click the buy now button and fill in your contact info,
shipping address, and payment details.
Your core strength treatment will arrive at your doorstep
in as little as three days anywhere in the United States.
Remember, if you are not 100% satisfied for any reason,
just send an email to the address printed on your bottle
and you will receive a prompt refund
of your full purchase price.
No questions asked.
Even if every bottle is empty,
you have nothing to lose and your mobility to regain.
Thank you for watching and God bless.